[Müzik]
7 veya 8 yaşındaydım Benim de yaşıt bir
arkadaşım daha Bizden de bir veya iki
yaş küçük bir çocuk daha 3 kişi çete
kurmaya karar verdik
Bandırma'da yaşıyoruz paşabayır
Mahallesi Paşa Sokak normalde böyle
televizyonlarda mafya dizileri filanın
çok oynadığı bir dönem değil ama bir
çete kurma Fikri geldi aklımıza Biz bir
çeteyiz
o kadar dik bir Bayır ki isminin hakkını
veriyor paşabayır Mahallesi
kaldırımın kenarında oturup ilk
Kurbanımızı beklemeye başladık
ilkokulda bize bir deney öğretmişlerdi
Dünyanın yuvarlak olduğunu nasıl anlarız
diye yaklaşan geminin önce dümenini
sonra bacasını sonra gövdesini falan
görüyoruz ya
bizim kurban o bayırdan yavaş yavaş
yukarıya doğru gelmeye başladı önce
başını gördük omuzlarını gövdesini
müdahale edebileceğimiz noktaya
geldiğini düşündüğümüz anda üçümüz
birden ayağa kalktık ona doğru koştuk
elindeki poşetlere saldırdık ve
poşetleri evine kadar taşıdık
pazardan dönen teyzelerin poşetlerini
taşıma Çetesi Böylece ilk eylemini
başarıyla gerçekleştirmiş oldu
yıllar sonra ben büyüdüm ve
bir eğitime katıldım 10 günlük eğitimin
9 gününde Eğitmen bir uygulama yapmamızı
istedi dedi ki Dışarıya çıkacaksınız
Yaklaşık 15 kişiyiz dışarıya
çıkacaksınız
gün boyunca 3 iyilik yapacaksınız en az
bir tanesinden karşılık alacaksınız
akşam geldiğinizde de konuyu konuşacağız
birlikte değerlendireceğiz her şeyi
bırakıyoruz paralarımız anahtarlarımız
Sadece kimlik yanımızda Kim olduğunuz
önemli
dışarıya çıktık
ben tabii böyle küçüklükteki çete
deneyiminden yola çıkarak hemen bir
marketin önünde pusuya yatarım bir teyze
bulurum geçmişteki profilde olduğu gibi
onun poşetlerini taşırım ilk şeyi yerine
getirmiş olurum diye düşündüm marketin
önünde pusuya yattım teyze çıktı yanına
gittim kibarca teyzeciğim Size yardımcı
olabilir miyim dedim bir şaşırdı teyze
olur dedi poşetlerin taşıdım o aynı
geçmişteki profilde olduğu gibi evin
önüne kadar gittik Normalde hiç Adetim
değildir Hani böyle bir iyilik yapayım
karşılığını alayım Hiç ama böyle Kapının
önündeyiz teyze cüzdanını karıştırıyor
Ben böyle bakıyorum yani bir bahşiş
verecek Ben de iyiliğin karşılığını
alacağım görevi yerine getirmiş olacağım
teyze karıştırdı karıştırdı bulamadı
çok da mahçup dedi ki ya sana
verebileceğim hiç param yok dedi hiç
önemli değil dedim bir hediye var mı
yani hani hediye ederken sizden bir anı
bile olabilir dedim ya hiçbir şey yok
yanımda dedi ben ilk iyiliği öyle pas
geçtim Ankara'da Tunalı Hilmi Caddesi
çıktım dışarıya yürüyorum caddede
yılbaşı arefesi Milli Piyango bileti
satan tekerlekli sandalyeye de bir bayi
şöyle bir baktım abiye sessiz sessiz
duruyor insanlar geçiyor gittim yanına
dedim ki abi sana yardım edeyim mi bir
durdu böyle nasıl yani dedi Dedim ki
yardım ederim burada hani bilet
satışlarına destek olurum belki Niye ki
dedi Dedim sana iyilik yapmak istiyorum
öyle geldiği içinden olur dedi ben böyle
geçtim yanına çıkmaz demeyin şansınızı
deneyin baktım Çok işe yaramıyor Neşeli
Günler filminde Ziya'nın jilet sattığı
bir reklam var ya böyle Reklam yapıyor
işte rahmetli Başkan kennediyor Taçsız
Kral Pele bak yani bal yer hepsi
şeylerini buna borçlular diye biletleri
göstermeye satmaya çalışıyorum
biraz da etkisini gösterdi insanlar
böyle bilet alıyorlar falan Bir saat
kadar takıldı orada
ardından bir şey isteyemeyeceğimi
anladım bir karşılık alamayacağım ikinci
iyiliği de yaptık Ben caddede dolaşmaya
devam ediyorum iş hanları var içerisine
Giriyorum çıkıyorum
Sahaflar vardı şeyde tunalıyım
Caddesi'ndeki iş hanlarının içerisinde
kitaplar dağınık yerlerde diyorum ki
kitapları yerleştireyim toz alayım Bana
bir tane en küçük kitabı hediye edin
Hani bu bunun karşılığı olarak yok
diyorlar ben bir türlü üçüncü iyiliği
yapamadım Otelin önüne geldim akşam
artık hava karardı
çaresiz içeriye gireceğim görevi
tamamlayamamışım ama ne yapacağımı
düşünüyorum yan tarafta bir kebapçı var
bir kamyonet yanaştı hır diye odunları
döktü çekti gitti Bir odunlara baktım
bir kendime baktım yaklaşık böyle bir
kıyafetteyim eğitime katılmaya gitmişim
sonuçta
girdim içeriye dedim ki abi dedim odun
geldi Ee dedi taşıyayım mı dedim bir
baktı böyle sen mi taşıyacaksın dedi
taşırım dedim iyi taşı dedi bir kasa
aldım odunları doldurdum taşıdım içeriye
Yarım saatte Üstüm kirpas salondan
içeriye girdim dedim ki başardım en
yüksek karşısı 5 lira almıştım 2008
yılında en yüksek karşılığı iyilik
karşılığında alan benim
o gün şunu anladım iyilik yapmak çok zor
İnsanlara iyilik yapmakta çok zorlandım
yetişkinken Halbuki bu çocukken çok
kolaydı
sokakta oynadığım oyunlar Bana iyilik
yapma şansını vermişti Demek ki şimdi
sokakta oyun oynayan çocuklar ne yapıyor
sorusunu bir düşünelim Belki de iyilik
yapmak için bir yerlerde bir mücadele
veriyorlar
yanınızdaki arkadaşınıza dönüp şöyle bir
yüzünüzü kapatıp bir açar mısınız şöyle
şöyle yapacaksınız
hemen
teşekkür ederim
C seslerini falan Duydum bu bizim
Muhtemelen oynadığımız bildiğimiz tahmin
ettiğimiz ilk oyunumuz
yokum varım ayrım kavuş
çocuğun yetişmesinde varlığında bir etki
yaratıyor Buz Devri filminin ilk
bölümünde kılıç dişli kaplan bulduğu
bebeğe bu sahneyi yapıyor böyle
şeyleri istiyor Çocuk gülüyor ona o
kadar
varlığımızı ispat ettiğimiz bir şey var
orada oyunun temelinde birazcık bu
yatıyor var olmak biz olmak hoşumuza
gidiyor Ben yaşıyorum varım kısmını o
oynadığımız küçücük oyun bile
sağlayabiliyor bir Düşünsenize ıssız
adaya düşseniz yanınıza alacağınızı şey
ne olur Şöyle bir aklınızdan geçirin Biz
çocukken çok oynardık bu oyunu ıssız
adaya düşsen yanına ne alırsın 3 tane
şey say
Ben bunu bir eğitimde oynattım takımlar
oluşturduk ve katılımcılar liste
yapıyorlar O listeyi önce bireysel
olarak yapıyorlar ardından da takım
olarak liste yapıyorlar bireysel
listelerle takım listelerini
karşılaştırıyoruz Hani etkileyiciliğiniz
takımla iletişiminiz ne kadar etki
yarattınız onu anlamaya çalışıyoruz
eğitimin temel amacı bu
takımlar sunumlarını yapıyorlar
listelerini açıklıyorlar o sırada
takımlardan bir tanesinin ilk sırasında
şey çıktı Ayna dedim ki yani ıssız adaya
düşmüşsünüz ve makyaj mı
tazeleyeceksiniz nedir Yani bu konu ile
ilgili takımı ikna eden kişi söz aldı
dedi ki hocam dedi
ıssız adaya tek başıma düşersem Var
olduğumu yaşadığımı kendime ispat etmek
zorundayım ki mücadeleye devam edeyim o
yüzden Ayna şart dedi hepimiz Evet ya
ilk sırada bir ayna olursa iyi olur diye
düşündük ya Kendi kendimize ispat
edeceğiz Çünkü yalnız kalamıyoruz En
kötü ihtimalle kendi kendimize kalacağız
ya da etrafımızda birileri olacak
birileri olacak onlarla oyun oynayacağız
oynadığımız oyunlar bizi
sosyalleştirecek
çok heveslenirim okuduğu kitaplardan
böyle direk cümle söyleyen insanlar
böyle benim idolümdür mesela Düşünsenize
Az önce size poşetlerini taşıdığımız
teyzenin hikayesini anlattım onu
anlatırken şöyle bir cümle kuruyorum
Dostoyevski'nin Karamazov Kardeşler
kitabında şöyle bir cümle geçer Hayat
iyi biz kötüyüz şimdi böyle bir cümleyi
söylemeyi çok istedim hayatım boyunca
ama hiç söyleyemedim Bugüne kadar hep
şunu düşünüyorum diyorum ki acaba
okuduğum kitaplar uçup gidiyor mu Ben
onları unutuyor muyum boşa zaman
kaybettiğim şeyler mi kitap okumak
sonra bir gün bir yerde bir ampul yandı
hayır aslında o okuduğum kitaplar
kaybolup gitmiyor benim hayatımı
şekillendiriyor kişiliğime bir şeyler
katıyor ama ben o esnada onu
farketmiyorum Yavaş yavaş büyüdükçe
ilerledikçe karşıma çıkıyor işte sokakta
Oynadığımız oyunlarda tam olarak böyle
bizi geliştiriyor kişiliğimizi
karakterimizi besliyor ve bir adım daha
ileriye gidebilmemizi sağlıyor
sokakta oynanan oyunlara ne oldu Onlar
bizim karakterimizi beslemeye devam
ediyorlar ve karakterimizi ilerleyen
noktalarda da besleyecekler
bir iş ilanı olsa karşınızda iş arıyor
olsanız o ilanda çok büyük olasılıkla
şöyle ifadeler göreceksiniz
iletişimi kuvvetli liderlik becerileri
olan özgüveni yüksek takım çalışmasına
yatkın
esnek zaman yönetimi konusunda iyi böyle
bir liste Hatta bu listeye böyle iki üç
şey daha ekleyelim işte vizyonu ileri
görüşlülüğü olan rekabetçi motivasyonu
yüksek maddelerinde eklersek
girişimcinin özelliklerine dolaşmış
oluruz şimdi önümüzde böyle bir iş ilanı
var bu bir kenarda Dursun biz tekrar bir
sokaklara dönelim
topunuzu aldınız dışarıya çıktınız şöyle
bir ses duyuyor olmam lazım
pabucu yarım çık dışarıya oynayalım
duydum size çıktım dışarıya
arkadaşlarımız geldi ve biz top oynamaya
başladık nasıl başlayacağız takımları
oluşturmamız lazım
takımlara liderlik edecek kişileri
seçeceğiz önce lider olmanın o dönemde
iki kriteri olabilir birçok iyi top
oynuyor olabilirsiniz iki topun sahibi
olabilirsiniz iş başvurusu yaptığınız
zamanları düşünün bu 2 kriteri
sağlayabiliyor musunuz sonra bir seçme
yerleştirme dönemi başlıyor şimdi iş
başvurusunun içerisindeyiz hala iki
yöntem var bir tanesi adımlamak aldım
verdim bilen var mı bilmiyorum ben seni
yendim Gazeteye İlan Verdim diye
ayağınızı üstte kalırsa ilk oyuncuyu Siz
seçme hakkına sahip olursunuz bir
lidersiniz biri benim veya ikinci bir
yöntem var Aç kapıyı bezirgan başı
oynayabiliriz Bu arada Bezirgan ticaret
yapan Tüccar demekmiş girişimciliği
böyle çocukluk aşamasından aşıladığımız
bir durum var ortada kapı hakkı ne
verirsin ne alırsın aşağıdan geçen
kişiyi yakaladık bu sefer hangi takımda
yer alacağını Oradaki kişi seçiyor Yani
benim seçecek sizin seçecek o karar
veriyor takımlarımızı oluşturduk
maç yapacağız futbol oynayacağız diyelim
ki 7 kişiyiz 3 kişi bir takımda 4 kişi
bir takımda eşitsizlik oldu
dayanamıyoruz Adalet gücümüz biraz
kabarıyor orada Diyoruz ki güçlü
kişilerden bir tanesi diğer takıma
geçsin de adaleti sağlayalım oradaki
adalet ve esneklik karşımıza çıkıyor
ardından zaman yönetimi yapmamız lazım
Çünkü Baba eve geldiğinde topumu verin
ben gideceğim diyeceksiniz büyük
ihtimalle Dolayısıyla zaman da doğru
yöneteceğiz ve eve döneceğiz
başka bir oyun saklambaç oynuyoruz
saklambaçta ebesisiniz diyelim ki bizler
kaçıştık saklandık bir yerlere bir
tanesi yakalandı dedi ki Elma dersem çık
armut dersem çıkma elma dedi Ben
çıkacağım o sırada size bir arkadaşımla
da yan yanayım diyelim ki o esnada
tam kafamı çıkardım Ebe beni gördü dedi
ki Oğuz orada sın Kırmızı montun var
şimdi hemen bir şey yapmamız lazım
empati kurmamız lazım montlarımızı
değiştirdik Ben sizin yeşil montu giydim
Siz benim kırmızıyı giydiniz çıktık
dışarıya Hayır bilemedin Çelik çömlek
patladı diye oyunu bıraktık orada beni
çok sevdiğim bir oyun var Japon Kale
diye biraz böyle futbol odaklı oldu ama
Japon Kale diye Japon Kalede bir daire
oluşturuyoruz Her birimizin birer tane
kalesi var ortaya bir tane top koyuyoruz
amaç gol atmak ama gol atarken de gol
yememeye çalışacağız
strateji geliştirmek zorundayız Çünkü
gol atmak üzere ileriye çıktığımız anda
topun yönü değişebilir ve gol
yiyebiliriz yanımdaki arkadaşımda bir
strateji oluşturuyorum diyorum ki gel
birlikte hareket edelim karşıdan böyle
gözümüze birini kestiriyoruz ona
yüklenelim paslaşarak gidelim şeye
atalım golü atalım ona tam çıkıyoruz
ileriye doğru o sırada yanımdaki
arkadaşım bana şöyle ufak bir yamuk
yapıyor topu alıyor ve hazır Kale boşken
benim kaleye gol atıyor dost kazığını da
öyle öğrenmiş olduk
oynadığımız her bir oyun bize bir şeyler
kattı
özgeçmişimizi de beslemeye başladı yavaş
yavaş şekillendirdik mesela seksek
oynamaya karar verdik çatılardan düşmüş
Bir kiremit parçasını bulup kareler
çizmemiz lazım düzgün Aynı büyüklükte
olması lazım Aynı zamanda da zıplarken
onun üzerinde
çizgilere basmayacak kadar uzak olmalı
taşı yeteri kadar uzağa atabilmemiz
lazım orada da düzen ve koordinasyonu
sağlamayı öğrendik görsel bakış açımızı
motor becerilerimizi geliştirdik sokakta
oynadığımız oyunlara ne oldu diye sorun
sokakta oyun oynayan çocukların
özgeçmişlerine girmeye başladı şimdi o
iş ilanı vardı ya oraya başvurduk
mülakata girdik bize sordu Liderlik
tecrübeleriniz ne bir WhatsApp grubunda
yönetici olarak görev yapıyorum gibi bir
şeyle sıyrılmaya çalıştık o olmadı dedi
ki aslında çok iyi Saklambaç oynuyorum
empati yeteneğim güçlüdür veya döndük
Diğer taraftan dedik ki Japon Kalede de
acayip strateji geliştiririm rekabet
becerilerim çok kuvvetlendirdim diye
dedi ki lütfen ciddiyete davet ediyorum
sizi gerçekten deneyimlerinizden
bahsedin Ne yani ben şimdi Öz geçmişime
Japon kaledeki deneyimlerimi yazamayacak
mıyım diye bir soru oluştu aklımızda
sokakta oynadığımız oyunlar Öz
geçmişimizi güçlendirdi
attığımız her adımın yaptığımız Her işin
bize katkısını görmeye başladık şimdi
bir sürü böyle
materyalle oynanan oyun var onlar olmasa
olmaz mı Şimdi ben bunları anlatırken
oyunları anlatırken yüzlerinizde şeyi de
görüyorum Böyle Aa evet ya oynasak
seksek Ne zamandır oynamıyoruz filan
diye
yapabiliriz Tabii ki Dışarıya çıkarız
çatıdan düşmüş Bir kiremit parçası
bulmamız lazım yalnız
malzemeyle kaplıyorlar Bir de güneş
enerjisi sistemleri var bulamayabiliriz
bir tebeşir bakalım zaten okulun
içerisindeyiz Pardon ya Board marker'lar
vardı değil mi Artık yerde çizmekte
zorlanabiliriz Peki ne yapsak Çelik
çomak oynasak mesela
bunun için boş bir arazi bulmamız lazım
henüz üzerine bina veya AVM yapılmamış
bir de arabaların camlarına dikkat
etmemiz lazım kaskolar karşılamayabilir
bizim gibi bir sorun yaratabilir
oyun oynamak bu kadar zor mu sokakta
oyun oynamak Gün geçtikçe biraz daha
zorlaşıyor Ben yetişkinlere oyun
oynatmaya çalıştığımda O da zor oluyor
Japon Kaleyi yetişkinleri oynatayım
dedim ama oyunu Manipüle edeceğim birden
fazla top sokmam lazım oyuna hazırlık
yapıyorum malzemeleri almaya gittim
lastik top alacağım memlekette lastik
Tok kalmamış haberiniz olsun daha kötüsü
mahalle bakkalı da kalmamış çünkü Lastik
Top nerede olur Mahalle bakkalının
önünde Filenin içerisinde asılı durur
mahalle bakkalı arıyorum yok top
arıyorum yok büyük marketlere gittim ben
lastik topu bulamadım çok zorlandım
sonra da basketbol topu almıştım içeride
oynayabilelim diye
bu kadar zor mu Evet maalesef zor
işimizi zorlaştırıyor mu zorlaştırıyor
mu peki Geldiğimiz noktada Ne yapacağız
şimdi konu biraz daha şeye geldi böyle
işte nerede o eski bayramlar biz
sokaklarda büyüdük efendim çok güzeldi
sokakta oynanan oyunlar Evet gelecek
içinde bir şeyler düşünmemiz lazım
gelecek için yapacağımız her şey
çocuklarımızın bizim sahip olduğumuz O
az önce o oyunlar bize ne kattı
sorusunun cevabına katkıda bulunacak
çocuklarımıza onun içinde bir şeyler
geliştirmek zorundayız
ama bir alternatif var mı var ekran
başında oynanan dijital oyunlar onlar da
hiç fena değil ya bu oyunları
geliştirenler de ayrıca çok güzel işler
yapıyorlar çocuklar bir şirket
kuruyorlar 2019 yılında 2021 yılında 1
milyar dolar değerlemeye ulaşıp unicorn
oluyor mesela ve yaptıkları şey oyun
geliştirmek çok güzel onlarda bizim
biraz daha böyle stratejik
kabiliyetimizi geliştirir mi mutlaka
geliştirir iletişim becerilerimiz Yalnız
bazı eksiklikleri kalır İşte benim
derdim bu Evet o ekran oyunları o
dijital oyunlarda bizi geliştirmeye
devam eder Fakat onları destekleyici
bazı şeylere ihtiyacımız var
Siz yakan topu oynarken yandığınızda
sokakta yakan top oynarken yandığınızda
oyunu en son Kaydettiğiniz yerden tekrar
başlama gibi bir imkanınız olmaz veya
Saklambaç oynarken ben bu profilden
sıkıldım dur profil değiştireyim
diyemezsiniz en fazla arkadaşınızla
montlarınızı değiştirirsiniz Ama bu
oyunların O az önce bahsettiğimiz
dijital oyunları karşı savaşında biraz
daha şanslı olduğunu gördüğümüzü
söyleyebilirim Sonuçta biz oyun oynamak
zorundayız bir çocuklarımıza oyun
oynatmak zorundayız 2 lütfen bulduğunuz
her fırsatta Oyun oynayın
telefonunuzdan bahsetmiyorum ya işte
seksek şimdi kim çizecek onu da
ayarlamak o kadar kolay olmayabilir ki
En kötü ihtimalle şu konuşmaların ilk
bölümüne ara verildiğinde o arada
dışarıda 3 tur taş kağıt makas
oynayabilirsiniz O zaman benimle
birlikte oyun oynamak isteyenler elime
[Alkış]
[Müzik]